Let's talk about relationships.
What are they anyway?
Well, a good way to think about them is that they carry relationship groups and filters.
Let's start by saying we want to select
all transactions where the PLU is tied to the category fruit.
When you select a category to be filtered on a report,
this is the same as telling your data model to
retrieve the values related to those categories.
The request is carried from the dimension where
the category lives to the fact table it's tied to.
We can see that the step we just took in
the grocery store report is the same as filtering for just fruit on the dimension table,
identifying the rows that are part of the fruit category.
Then using the PLU key to carry this request from the dimension table to
the fact table where the data model chooses just
those transaction rows with those PLU keys.
Relationships work pretty well,
but they have to be pointed in the right direction.
Sometimes Power BI will really try to help you by creating a relationship on your behalf.
Because you only have a small amount of information in your transaction table,
it might guess wrong.
It might assume that the relationship should be
filtering in the opposite direction of what you intended.
If in the same example we had created a relationship that pointed from
the transaction table to the dimension table
Power BI might still accept this as a relationship,
but you'd see the side effects in the report.
With the arrow pointing towards the dimension table,
any filter you apply to the field on that dimension table has no path to another table.
When you try to create a filter based on the fruit category,
there's nowhere really for that filter to go.
Instead, Power BI is expecting that based on the relationship,
you're going to apply filters using the fields
on the transaction onto the dimension table.
Something like "Select all dimension rows where the PLU is tied to the subtotal $2.97."
It just doesn't make sense.
Relationships also only work if they're connected by the intended keys.
This is an unlikely but possible scenario where
someone linked up the variety column with the PLU.
This is likely to trigger something like a many-to-many relationship,
which if you've been building your dimension tables
to ensure each row should have a unique key,
should tell you right away that you goofed.